We learnt that objects are visible because
of the light getting reflected from
their surfaces.
This reflected light enters our eyes and we
see that object.
What happens inside the human eye when light
rays enter it?
What is it that
helps us see the things around us?
The human eye is roughly spherical in shape.
What we’re going to do in this
video is understand the different parts of
the eye in short… not in extreme
detail.
Let’s begin!
The outer layer of the eye is called the CORNEA.
It is white in colour and
transparent.
Transparent?
Yes, it means that it allows light to pass
through it!
In fact, cornea REFRACTS or bends the light
passing through it.
And much of
the refraction inside the eye is done by cornea
only!
But wait, it not only refracts light but also
protects the inner parts of the eye.
It acts like a tough front wall of the eye
protecting the interior of
the eye from accidents and also does not allow
foreign particles to enter.
Okay,
so this was all about the outer layer of the
eye.
Let’s now talk about the things
present INSIDE.
Behind the cornea there is a dark muscular
structure called the IRIS.
Iris
determines the colour of the eye.
For instance when we say that a person has
blue eyes, it means that the colour of the
iris of person’s eye is blue.
Now there
is a small opening at the centre of the iris
for the light to enter.
Do you know
what it’s called?
It is called the PUPIL.
The Iris actually acts like a shutter of a
camera.
It controls the amount of light
entering the eye by enlarging or shrinking
and thereby adjusting the size of the
pupil.
For example, when you focus the light from
the torch directly into a
person’s eye the iris shrinks.
This is because the intensity of light is
too much
for the eyes to bear!
The shrinking iris stops the unwanted light
from entering
through the pupil.
And when it’s dark or when there’s less
light, it expands
allowing more light to enter through the pupil.
Ok, what happens next?
The light that enters through the pupil falls
on the LENS kept behind.
This lens
is a BICONVEX LENS.
What is a convex lens?
We already know what a biconvex
lens is.
It is a lens which is thicker at the centre
than the edges.
It is a CONVERGING
LENS.
That is, it focuses all the light at one point.
In a normal regular eye this
point is somewhere here, on this inner boundary
called RETINA.
Why do i say a
normal eye?
Well, in a defective eye, this point of focus
may lie either in front
of the retina or behind the retina.
We will talk about this defect of eye in our
future videos but first let’s go back to
our normal eye where light is focussed
ON the retina.
Retina is at the back of the eye and marks
the inner layer of the
eyeball.
Retina contains lots of NERVE CELLS that sense
the light.
The nerve cells are of
two kinds namely CONES which are sensitive
to bright light and RODS which
are sensitive to dim light.
The message or sensation is then transferred
to the brain along the optic
nerve.
Ok, let’s quickly recap what we learned
about human eye.
Human eye has a roughly spherical shape.
The outer part of an eye called
CORNEA is a thick white transparent wall,
which protects the eye from
accidents and keeps the foreign particles
from entering inside.
Behind the
cornea, the colourful part of the eye called
IRIS is present.
It has a small
opening at the centre called PUPIL.
Iris controls the light entering through the
pupil by contracting and expanding.
Behind the pupil there is a converging lens
which focuses the light on retina.
Retina consists of two types of nerve cells
namely cones and rods.
They
transfer the message through the optic nerve.
That’s a lot of information to digest!
In next video we will talk more about
this lens present inside the eye and will
discuss its functioning.